hello we're glad you joined us for
today's webinar prefrontal control of
learned fear and avoidance I am
Christina mahalik of labyrinth and I'll
be moderating this session today's
educational web seminar is presented by
labyrinth cell right the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider a virtual events in webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning to learn more visit la Cruz com
let's get started you can post questions
to the speaker during the presentation
while they're fresh in your mind to do
so simply type them in the Q&A box which
will open when you click on the green
Q&A button found at the lower left of
the presentation window questions will
be answered after the presentation to
the large this slide window could on the
screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of this side window if you
experience technical problems seeing or
hearing the presentation just click on
the support button found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report their problem by clicking on the
green 28 button at the lower left of the
screen this is an educational webinar
and this offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the CC button
located in the bottom left hand corner
of your web page and follow the process
of obtaining your credit I now present
today's speaker Gregory quirk PhD
against professor University of Puerto
Rico raised in Southern Connecticut
court went to Northwestern University in
evanston illinois for his graduates
under for his undergraduate training one
of the first nu students to major in
neuroscience he worked in the laboratory
of dr. re Rotenberg studying dentate
granule cells
in the hippocampus in memory he then
pursued a PhD in neural and behavioral
science at suny downstate in Brooklyn
New York working with doctors Robert
Hume your mentor John l2b and James be
ranked studying place cells in the
hippocampus and internal cortex this was
followed by a Fulbright fellowship to
establish the first neuroscience
research laboratory in Honduras at UNH
teju Cedella focus on malnutrition and
developing sea and ass following it has
postdoctoral fellowships at NYU in the
laboratory of dr. Joseph Lido studying
cortical amygdala circuits in
acquisition and extinction of
conditioned fear Parkman returns to
Latin America in 1997 to establish his
own research laboratory at home school
of medicine now Health Sciences
University in puerto rico in 2007 he
news his loss to the University of
Puerto Rico School of Medicine in San
Juan over the past 20 years course
research program on fear learning has
brought competitive research grants
high-profile publications and for us
training opportunities for undergraduate
and doctoral students wedding in Puerto
Rico such reports will now begin his
presentation the floor is all yours
okay thank you Christina I am very quick
and I'm happy to be here at lab roots
lecture on prefrontal control with
learned here and avoidance I'm starting
with a beautiful picture of Puerto Rico
where I am that's not my office
unfortunately I wish it was it's a small
island off the coast of Puerto Rico
called kayo Santiago which is a rhesus
macaque research facility that for
reaches accounts and we do some research
there okay I like to start with this
quote from Marie Curie the first woman
Nobel laureate nothing in life is to be
feared it's only to be understood that's
very of very encouraging but it also in
a way is is an introduction for cortical
regulation of here or cognitive therapy
in a sense can we sink down our fears to
the control them with ourselves so what
makes us afraid some fears are thought
to be an ink like snakes for example or
the fear of heights this is the CN tower
in toronto where you're supposed to walk
across a glass floor and it really is
terrifying I went to do with myself and
had real trouble getting across that
floor because i am mitchell is saying
i'm i'm going to die but my prefrontal
cortex is saying no they don't kill
tourists and you're probably going to be
fine so i did make it across but most
fears are learned through conditioning
or instruction so how do we respond to
danger stimuli and we can respond it
passively such as freezing or startling
or actively such as avoidance or or
fight or flight now these conditions few
responses that occur with the trauma can
later trigger anxiety and here and this
is a feature of all the anxiety
disorders so post-traumatic stress
phobias panic disorder and even the
pressure compose
this word so the questions of our lab
are what regulates the retrieval and
expression of these learn fear responses
and how do the few responses compete
with negative drive so let's start with
these passes your responses are freezing
so this video shows rats here in Puerto
Rico they're pressing a bar for food
under receiving a pellet in a tray and
they they're waiting for the tone okay
there that that light but just turn on
indicates the tone and the tone means
nothing to them so they don't they don't
stop the end now hit in the conditioning
phase the tone is on it will terminate
with a mild shock okay there it is we do
that a few times and the next day this
is the first presentation of the tone
and that's freezing in fact we've
inserted the memory of tone shot in the
animal's brain and you can see the rat
on the lower right is trying to break
through his here to get closer to the
food which is typical of anxiety
disorders that they prevent us from
achieving goals so we can measure this
freezing with video programs it
increases during to the commissioning
phase then we give the tone without the
shock and music decreases extinguishers
and then the next day you can see
there's a memory for a few extinctions
of animals that have the extinguishment
now the extinction doesn't erase the
original learning it should just wait a
matter of time you can see that the
extinguished freezing comes back in this
case to its full original value over a
number of days it's called spontaneous
recovery so this suggests that the fear
memory are regulated so what are the
circuits that regulate the expression
and extinction of these of these fear
so obviously the emitter is the key
structure here it gets inputs from the
thalamus and the cortex gets tone in
chalk information that's integrated in
the amygdala the lateral and basal
nuclei and it's really the central
nucleus that's the output of the
amygdala to mediate the various aspects
of conditioned fear to the hypothalamus
and midbrain now the prasada cortex has
reciprocal connections with the label
and really can control on the output of
a nikuman and we're going to focus on
these two subdivisions of the prefrontal
cortex of the rat the prelimbic and
infirmary areas and we can ask what did
these areas do by infusing a GABA
receptor agonist feasible to inactivate
these areas so we do that in the
pre-olympic cortex the animals have
trouble expressing or showing their
conditions here so but they have no
trouble extinguishing as you can see if
we inactivate the inside of the cortex
in contrast the expression of the
Commission fear is normal but they have
trouble distinguishing extinguish much
more slowly and the next day they show
no memory of the extinction so that we
think this preliminary is importance of
the retrieval or the expression of the
conditions here whereas this insulin
decarious importance of the extinction
now the PLL areas projecta different
different parts of the amygdala
prelimbic to the basal nucleus mostly in
the insula limbic too please
intercalated neurons that inhibit Mikula
output and this is led to circuits such
as this that are thought to be involved
in the expression and extinction of
conditioned fear from presented cortex
the basal Nicola or from the insulin bit
cortex to the interior intercalated
cells to turn off now we've been
recently visiting these circuits without
the kinetic techniques so here in
optogenetics we can use either channel
adoption express channel adoption or
hailer adoption which is activated by
laser light
to allow the flow of either sodium or
chloride ions to activate or inhibit
neurons and we use a cam kinase to
promoter so these are the neurons that
express these reductions are going to be
most likely projection cells or
excitatory neurons so for example the
prelimbic projects to the basolateral
amygdala have saved but it also projects
to in Salamis the midline thalamus the
video dorsal and kyra particular area
and then that projects to the central
amygdala so this is an indirect circuit
in which the prefrontal cortex can
control expressionist here this shows
the entered a label in the central
nucleus with injections in the power
ventricular normal so to address these
indirect projections we used
optogenetics for Risa valmont a postdoc
in the lab use epigenetic techniques to
express in this case halo rhodopsin in
the presented cortex so you can see the
preliminary to expression of the yellow
freshman Russia protein that indicates
Taylor adoption now and when we shine
the laser yellow laser light the action
potentials are reduced now the beauty of
optogenetics is you can also activate
just the terminals or inhibit just the
terminals here so we can express the
Heller adoption in the pre-olympic
cortex and shine a light in the
terminals in the thalamus as i seed the
inputs from the crease of the cortex
periventricular families in this case
we're recording from the periventricular
neurons when we shine a light and
inhibit the pre-olympic inputs we get in
addition as you see on the left or on
the right we get excitation suggesting
that there's some sort of feed-forward
inhibition of this of this platinum so
how the crush
is what do these pathways are these
pathways necessary have been tree
volunteer what roles they play so to
address this servicio in lab use heller
adoption in rafts at two different time
points after conditioning for the six
hours or seven days and he noticed that
when he inhibited the premotor cortex
freezing was reduced at both time points
however when he inactivated the
projections to deliver freezing was
reduced only at the early time point six
hours but not at the seven-day time
point when activated the projections
from prolific to the curvature go
Salamis he saw the opposite result the
freezing was reduced only the loan time
point but not the short then when he
inactivated the projections from the
partnership goes almost to be Nikola he
got the same pattern a reduction of
reasoning at the long time point but not
the short and looking the next day you
can see here that the the freezing is
still reduced even in the absence of the
of the laser light suggesting that
activation these pathways may be
important for maintaining the fear
memory but it certainly seems like
there's a shift from the projections to
the basolateral amygdala to the
projections of Salamis a time-dependent
shift in the circus that that mediate
retriever a few now some implications of
these findings are that it changes the
way we think about the current model the
fear regulation based mostly at least
twenty four-hour time points that the
memories are changing revolving
appellant and post-traumatic stress is
usually involves older memories so it
asks is this time dependent shifting of
retrieval circuits involved and could it
be could it be used clinically and what
are the mechanisms of this recruitment
of this chronic area and what are the
advantages
so the paraventricular thalamus receives
inputs from the number of different
areas throughout the frontal cortex the
campus and we lead brain and the
amygdala and it turns projections back
to many of these structures so it has a
unique connectivity and it could be
doing all of these things that if it's
suggested by by various authors we could
coordinate the fear memory with other
responses such as arousal and anxiety
chronic stress or food seeking and
reward via its projections to the
nucleus accumbens and this is the the
the back opsys that we're following up
on now so here we modify the task so
that the animal can press a bar for food
it only gets the food if a light is
turned on so we condition the animals to
press only when the cue light is on and
not with the lights off then on before
we either get the food again the light
as normal or we omit the food so they
don't get the food that they expected
now we can activate the general adoption
the perfect Rick you later on when we do
that we see that it reduces the pressing
for food both when the food is available
and when the food is emitted as you can
see here on day four and Bay five I
think we have a video of that here so
those here at the laser is often these
trials the writers waiting for the light
to turn on and then it starts pressing
the borrow for food now the hailer
adoption light is going to be turned on
the Rangers we turned on when the light
is turned on only in the in the left
hand rat the writers of control and you
can see that with this act with this
pathway activated the general adoption
the animal is not pressing for food on
the left where it is on the right
so this pathway turns off the food
seeking behavior now we can do the
reverse we can inhibit or silence this
pathway by expressing camera adoption in
the paraventricular nucleus been a
shining light in the movies that laser
yellow laser in the nucleus accumbens
and we do that we get a very interesting
pattern results when the food is
available we get no effect of an
activating this password however when
the food is automated the press rate
increases only when the food is emitted
so that suggests that under normal
conditions this pathway is recruited
under the conditions where the animal
doesn't get something that it wanted or
easily think of a be similar vs.
conditions so for example you think that
this partnership the thalamus could come
online to coordinate food speak English
aversive events so for example if a cat
which is a predator program appears then
the prelimbic cortex can activate
private supersonic neurons that then
projected the central nucleus and
trigger these fear response but at the
same time it can activate private
recording neurons that projected the
nucleus accumbens shell and decrease
food season so the animal can decrease
from seeking and orient towards the
predator and escape now let's take a
ship and talk about the active your
responses of the or avoidance avoidance
can be thought of something as possible
because it can be considered a coping
strategy that reduces the likelihood of
dangerous but it also can be seen as
something negative it's excessive in
anxiety disorders and it interferes with
the goals and reduces the opportunities
for naturally occurring extinction
obviously it's be if just the patient's
avoiding a famous associate of the
trauma it will not learn that that
stimulus is not serious
so we've modified our air conditioning
task by inserting a barrier at the
opposite end of the case that the animal
can jump on and avoid the shock they
call this tie for mediated avoidance
this time avoidance has a cost because
it competes with the food when the
animals sitting on the platform it can't
reach the bar so we think this is
similar to clinical avoidance and unlike
freezing this is really a decision that
the animal has to make that can we based
on multiple factors such as the crew
timing and fear so it's going to be more
complex than than fair condition which
is a more reflections or scoffs and
therefore may have a more complex
circuitry them as well in fair condition
however we're in a position now that we
know so much about the circuitry of your
condition to use it to understand
avoidance even though avoids of a long
history of research now where the time
we can be really returned to
understanding the circuits of avoidance
acquired ok here is a video of rest that
have been training this avoidance task
depression of our for food and the light
will come on the tone will come on in
the moment there's the tone now they
know the shock occurs at the end of the
tone but they don't waste much time
getting on that platform and waiting out
the tone now look at the rats and the
lower north RF you see they're trying to
get close to the ball you can see that
attention of conflict ok now the tone is
off and they can head back to the bar
and continue pressing for food
okay so this is the work of christians
over there was a graduate student in the
lab and basically this shows that we
train right over nine or ten days in
this task the blue line shows the
increase in avoidance and the red line
shows the decrease in freedom to the
tone and she so if this typical
avoidance test that the animal learned
to avoid to it has control no longer is
afraid of the tongue the green line
shows the rate of pressing during the
inter trial integral which was depressed
initially but then comes back to normal
levels so here at the end after ten days
the animal looks quite normal as long as
it can do the voices the question that
is one of the structures that are
necessary for expression of Adelaide's
so we started with usable in either
these three structures the prolific
cortex the ventral striatum or in
basolateral amygdala and to our surprise
in activating any of these areas or all
these areas in create a decreased
avoidance but not in the same way if you
look at freezing in activating the
basolateral amygdala also reduced reason
whereas in activating the prelimbic and
the stratum did not beat extrusion so we
think that the inactivation of BL a
reduced or eliminated the tone shock
association and that's why I avoidances
was lost whereas these areas loss of
inactivation produced the loss of the
avoidance response again will revert to
freeze the musical so I think it's
giving this projection that is mediating
the avoidance option with the avoidance
response under these conditions in
danger on the left you have the surface
of fear conditioning the prelimbic can
activate the liquid to dry freezing by
on the right we think that the during
avoidance of pre living activates the
ventral striatum to generate the
avoidance response and I think this is a
direct projection here we can combine
see sauce which is a activity marker
with retrograde tracers such great
labeling injected via the ventral
striatum or the base
Nicola so you can see here the cells
that are labels label the green are
neurons that are expressing sauce and
animals that are expressing avoidance
you can see the premotor cortex and
these same area tends to be a label that
cells that project to the ventral
striatum but not so much cells that
project to the basolateral amygdala so
indeed Sean on the far right you can see
that the theorem we cells are activated
by thoughts our tent project to the
ventral striatum than to be making so
again we can use optogenetics to
investigate this and this is the work of
maria da lat postdoc in the lab but she
did was expressed hey lurid actually
arch rhodopsin in the premotor cortex to
inhibit or silenced the prolific neurons
so she can inhibit or a silence with
responsibly cells that shown here and
anesthetize animals but then in behavior
she expresses the arch rhodopsin in
either in the prolific cortex both the
rostral prelimbic and the coral clinton
but in both cases in activating the
cells have no effect and you can see
here in on the on day 11 when the town
is on there is no effect there's no
reduction in the time spent on the
platform and we'll still are still
avoiding both in the rostral olympic and
the cartilage so there is a puzzle
because our use of all data suggested
that there was in effect was a reduction
in the middle so why their disagreement
between reason all silencing or
inhibiting and the archer adoption so to
address this we thought the let's let's
look and see what the prelim ignorance
are actually doing do they signal the
avoidance so to do this maria implanted
animals and recorded from granitic
neurons in the animals as their they
hear the tone and then start the
avoidance
and she recorded across a large range of
rostral and carlo premotor cortex and
you can see on the bottom that you saw
both excitatory and inhibitory responses
cells that they were excited to the tone
or inhibits of the time but when you
look at the percentage of animals that
that shows the percentage of cells that
show these responses about equivalent
levels show excitation versus inhibition
in rats that were training avoidance but
in naive labs that we never trained
there in the chamber with the platform
and a borrower but they're not
conditioned at all you get the same
percentage of excitation but very little
or no avoidance no inhibition so that
suggests that we it's really intimate
Ori responses that are correlated with
avoidance not the excitatory response
and you can see that and furthermore the
majority of these inhibitory these cells
that were inhibited are located in the
rostral created the cortex not the coral
so how could we block this inhibitory
response to find out is it necessary for
avoidance so we use epidemics again the
news channel adoption to to stimulate
these neurons now the neurons that are
showing the inhibition are shown on the
left as blue dots in a against the
background of previous data from our
laboratory looking at spike with and
basil firing rates so the small gray
triangles indicate projection punitive
projection neurons with long spikelets
and and slow firing rings whereas these
light great cells are fugitives
inhibitory interneurons the child hi
firing rates and no spices so it looks
like these cells showing inhibition rd
projection rods on the right you can see
the average inhibitor response would
last about 10 seconds a little bit more
and it drops the firing rate from an
average of six Hertz to about two hurts
so shown here sells firing about 600
tone comes on it drops its rate 22 hurts
but we can use general adoption to
stimulate the neurons at the tone on set
at four Hertz which can bring the rate
back up to six or innocence maintaining
the basal firing rate throughout the
tongue then we asked if this would
affect the one okay what you're seeing
here is the same rat without the laser
on the left of liquid laser on the right
there's the tone at this very slow for
heard stimulation then you see the
animal with the laser it's it's not
pressing about for food so it's not like
there's no clear notice is a problem but
it's not using the platform and the
tongue goes off and it goes back to
depression so looking at the data here
is good data indeed you can see that
there was a there was a inhibition of
the avoidance response with this for her
stimulation of the shells in the rostral
free of the cortex but not in the coral
print of the cortex in agreement with
the location of between hit droid
neurons in inhibited neurons were in
rushville three other quarters
furthermore stimulation at two herds had
no effect so it's specific to the
frequency importance so it seems that an
inhibitory signal is important in the
rostral feel of the cortex it gets
confirmation from the amygdala there if
there's convergence with other inputs to
produce inhibition and then this then
perhaps disinhibited strudel neurons
that are involved in avoidance perhaps
we like other cortical areas the rostral
permanent cortex can end on fast biking
in turn ons in the ventral striatum
which command inhibit medium sponding
moment okay what about extinction of
awards well we showed some years ago
that the infinite cortex is involved
again with mucin all inactivates in
front of the cortex just prior to
extinction the animals extinguish their
avoidance but the next day they show no
evidence of the except the extinction
memory in other words are unable to
consolidate okay level interestingly on
day 12 even though they have excess
avoidance they do not have excess losses
so they're not more afraid of the of the
tone they just do can't stop doing the
avoidance now a more recent work done by
the lease versus the dollar ND PhD
student in laboratory I've looked at the
role of brain-derived neurotrophic
factor in in influenza cortex so when we
inhibit or use an antibody to be gained
a prohibited in essence of the cortex it
also impairs avoidance extinction memory
as you can see here the animals are
responding as a family that had
extinction first of all what he did was
to combine immunocytochemistry for bdnf
protein together with retrograde tracers
injected into the implicit cortex so
here's the hippocampus hippocampal
neurons are shown here red or if the
kappa learns the projective ease of the
cortex and those that are yellow are
those neurons that they also expressed
very introspective and indeed after
extinction training those double-labeled
earns increased suggesting that the
input from the hippocampus is the one
that's bringing this PDMS interest
that's important for extinction
and in agreement that we were using the
crisper cast nine system to block the
production of probity massive eventual
of the campus and indeed when that's
done we get the same effect that the
animals can extinguish but again their
memory for the extinction is this blog
suggesting that be again the B&S and
eventual the capital inc what is
important for avoidance extinction and
it's important to remember that brain
derived neurotrophic factor is
implicated in PTSD OCD the levels are
reduced so this could be part of the
mechanism for of these accelerated
avoidance in the situation now some
other directions in the civil rights
tech you'd be using is to maximize the
food fear conflict and we in the videos
I showed you so far the animals know
that when the tone comes on there on the
platform they can't press for food but
they know that the tone goes off they
can go back to Korea bar and press in
the electron interval so we modified the
task that they could only press the
governing retrieves food during the tone
so mr. work of effective our Rivera
graduate student lab but he did with
first conditioning animals avoidance
tasks so that they were avoiding quite a
bit and they're showing very little bar
pressing to the to the part where very
little bar crushing during the Tom then
after that conditioning he then
Commission's animals to do a delight
reward condition so in this case they
the light turns on that's when the
barrage armed they're able to get food
so learn to increase their pressing in
the presence of light then he gives both
the tone and the light at the same time
that's the conflict the animal has can
only press the food during the tone
what are they doing so the animals show
an interesting month man will show this
interesting property where they tend to
slowly decrease the amount of poisons
and increase the amount of pression
remember the shop does come at the end
of the tone so they can basically time
out the interval and increase the amount
of food that they're receiving till the
end they're avoiding about the same
amount at the oppression and this video
of that shown below here so the light is
off tone is off and now they turn on
together the tone and the light so he's
pressing very fast if it gives a short
time now to shoot as much food as we can
and that's it now he's on the platform
again waiting for the end of time even
though he's a bit conflicted there all
right comes off and now he can go back
to the barb now the majority of these
animals do this this we call this tiny
behavior but a small percentage about
temperature and the animals show a
different a different kind of response
actually press they voice less and press
more so as if they're not concerned
about the shock so we call these food
preferring animals and another subgroup
here avoids almost entirely and and and
presses not at all so these are platform
for preferring animals so these two
subgroups theta there are three
different subgroups or responses in this
conflict task and interestingly this
this conflict induces some change in
their responses and we're using now see
sauce and then later optogenetics to
modulate these different subtypes
with all these also museums passed a
model excessive repulsive compulsions
many RC decomposers represent can be
thought of as representing avoidance or
perceived threat so for example
hand-washing repetitive hand-washing to
avoid infection or disease now there's a
treatment for OCD that is called
exposure with response prevention or ERP
the person is taken and exposed to their
stimulus miss cases if it's infection or
germs and maybe they touch a toilet seat
and then they're prevented from washing
their hands for a period of time the
salt here is to actually extinguish this
compulsive behavior so we can modify our
task to to address this so we have
weakened condition animals to go on the
platform then we can extinguish over a
number of days but by putting in a
barrier Plexiglas barrier says the
animal cannot go on the platform you can
see it but it can't go on then we remove
the merit barrier and an ask do they go
on the platform or not even though
they've extinguished their their few
responses we call this extinction with
responsible engine so again they get the
conditioning then three days of
extinction training with the very
presence and then we remove the garbage
and what you see here is that the
majority of animals shown in green here
do not belong the platform in other
words they stay by the food bar and the
tone is on and they've learned their
extinction but a small percentage about
twenty-five percent still go on the
platform despite the extinction we look
at those animals that shown in pink you
and during the extinction but there's
phase they actually show elevated
freezing levels so they seem to be more
afraid in the presence of the barrier in
other words more more afraid the fact
that they can't announce leave the
platform
now we can we can reverse this
persistent avoidance with two different
manipulations one is an activation of
the lateral orbitofrontal cortex here's
usable in the lateral orbital area and
in animals that showed announced that
showed that this is avoidance they now
you no longer show the persistent ones
similarly deep brain stimulation a
high-frequency stimulation of the
internal capsule or the nucleus
accumbens internal capsule area in the
in the rat again during the extinction
training they extinguished normally but
it moves or eliminates the persistent
avoid and shorted pets now interestingly
the conditions freezing did not change
them even animals so these manipulations
don't reduce fear they just reduce the
oils and suggest that the lateral
orbital input to the rostral prolific
cortex may be important in gaining or
modulating avoidance after extinction
and after this situation another way to
think about it is that these inputs may
help to devalue the the platform after
extinction and this may be a problem in
OCT is that it platform is not devalue
our extinction another experiment that
this task has being done by another
postdoctoral lab 27 Martinez Rivera um
he's asked if the amount of conditioning
the extent of conditioning training
affects the persistent avoidance so he
has two groups one that's trained at
eight days and one that's trained at
twenty days of a very prolonged
condition both groups learn the
avoidance task and reduce their freezin
but then they're put into the extinction
of this cross prevention and then give
it a test and we notice there's
something very interesting that across
the four days of extinction training the
20-day group they start off the same but
they
trouble extinguishing their condition
freezing responses like the 8-day group
does in other words they seem to
maintain an elevated fear response
during expression and then when they're
tested without the barrier they do show
increased avoidance but not increased
fear because presumably this avoidance
they're doing is is removing the fear
that they have so again it's may be
related to obsessive compulsive disorder
in a sense that this prolonged or
habitual expression of the other
compulsions can then exacerbate this
kind of dependence on the other
compulsion to reduce you so we're now
using optogenetics to manipulate these
circuits to to move the rats for one
group to another so summarizing we
extinction expression of the avoidance
the amygdala gives tone information the
rostral print of the cortex supriya
Lovick then projects to ventral striatum
which I projects to the substantia [ __ ]
reticulata to mediate these avoidance
responses now an extinction means when
the cortex can pivot either at the level
of amygdala or at the level destroy that
we agreed to reduce the avoidance it
depends on inputs from venture of the
campus to both prelimbic and it's
Olympic using this brain derived
neurotrophic factor and we took the
lateral or Olympic to Roscoe Columbus
it's important in getting the value on
after extinction of leaves and we're
particularly interested now in studying
these the interaction of these different
inputs using optogenetic techniques to
study how do we zip with interact in the
rostral in the cortex comedian and
control avoidance
ok this human homologs of rodent prelim
ignition of the cortex based on fear
conditioning the prelimbic cortex is
thought to be the dorsal anterior
cingulate cortex and the insulin deck is
thought to be homologous to the
ventromedial prefrontal cortex this is
based on years of data in to your
conditioning and extinction now unit
studies of avoidance are are rare and
they're just beginning to to be done
this is work from daniela Schiller
looking at a level of woman's past where
the subject is asked to keep moving that
green dot from one side to another
without to learn that they not told
ample earned that they keep shuttling it
back and forth they'll they'll prevent a
shock if they don't it will get a shot
to those changes now she scans these
people in the MRI shows that that when
they're doing this avoidance response
there's an increase in activity in the
in the striatum in addition of when
they're doing the avoidance past there
is an increase in or correlated activity
between the most roskill part of the of
the prefrontal cortex and the caudate
nucleus and a slightly more caudal part
of this anterior cingulate and the
Enigma so we think it is this this dis
ting this rossville area is is
coordinating with the striatum in
avoidance and recent work from Mohammed
Milan's group has shown in human
subjects with peak with posttraumatic
stress disorder using the pet fdg to
look at resting activity defines that
it's really this most roshell area
that's correlated with the avoidance
symptoms in the station so again in both
of these studies are indicating there's
something very important about this more
rostral anterior cingulate area in
mediating or modulating avoidance
okay that's that's the best to talk here
is the great people that I work with in
Puerto Rico the graduate students and
postdocs that I've already pointed out
in talk but in particular I'd like to
just point out again post-doctoral
Bishop the long texts really started
optogenetics in Puerto Rico and is now
setting up his own lab at the University
Texas in Houston our work is supported
by funding from the National suits of
Mental Health and the National Science
Foundation and also we are universally
Puerto Rico and I'd like to make a plug
for a new exciting journal than an
associate editor at called the science
of learning this is part of the nature
partner journals to try and integrate
what we know about learning and memory
with education in other words the field
of education what is neuroscience have
to save education and vice versa so this
is a good time to submit to this journal
and it's a really efficient and thanks
very much for your attention thank you
dr. Clark for your informative
presentation a quick reminder for our
audience on how to submit questions
simply type in in the Q&A box stand by
clicking on the greatest Q&A button at
the lower left of the presentation
window dr. Park Slope answered many
questions as time permits and with that
would pop in to us the questions such
reports the first question of the day as
do the same pvt neurons project to both
the nucleus X Cubans in amygdala or are
they separate
ventricular Nasser turn on here and can
turn on here or or turn off the feeding
we have done some double labeling
experiments and seeing that in fact the
majority of the projections that we're
seeing there are many more projections
to the a comment than to the amygdala
which is consistent with whiskey would
be published anatomical data there are
some double labeled neurons that are
some neurons that projected both targets
but very very few and those might be
important in terms of both manipulate at
the same time turning off the turning on
the fear by projections to bigelow at
the same time is turning all the
pressing through the projection screen
accumbens but mostly they are they are
not by bi-directionally projecting thank
you for your answer next question bdnf
is also involved in those extensions
extinction of fear and extinction of
avoidance are there any differences
between the two as a great question um
yeah that it's a good question i think
that the there are some differences are
interested in the differences and one of
the key ones is that we've looked at
bdnf in the extinction of fear again
it's important necessary needs some of
the cortex but it's not important and
it's not necessarily the prelimbic court
case in avoidance of its it's different
it's necessary in both structures both
the insula limbic and the prelimbic so
we think that the prolific cortex is so
critical to the expression of the
ordinance that it can be manipulated
modulated by beating us being allergic
inputs unlike your condition which does
not depend on the freedom the cortex for
the expression of the fewer ok next
thank you for your answer our last
question of the day s is the conflict
conflict asked you show different
subtypes of rats based on the reaction
to food fear complex disease subtype
show any differences during the early
phases of avoidance training um actually
uh they show very few differences so I
think I think the question is they in
the concert they show these different
subtypes some that prefer the platforms
from the prefer the avoidance other
prefer the food we look during the
conditioning phase and during the
conditioning training we don't see any
differences between these groups earlier
in the training so it suggests the
interesting possibility that this
difference between the subgroups
developed or arises at the moment of the
conflict we can't we're not able to
predict which rests which rats will go
into which subtypes prior to conflict
training so it's a novel way of handling
the conflict they have different
approaches to handling the competence I
would like to once again at thanks dr.
court for his presentation do you have
any final comments he's like three of us
today thank you again for the
opportunity and I'm adopted too happy to
to answer any other questions or
comments through email my email address
is on the last slide and feel free to
email in many questions about the work
of comments and I'm happy to to to
answer them thanks again it's been our
pleasure I want to save the audience for
joining us today and thank lat roots for
today's educational webcast this webcast
can be viewed on demand through june
twenty
teen Lavery's will alert you via email
when is available for replay we
encourage you to share that with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live events this is Christine Hollis
with levers and we'll see you here next
time goodbye